- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is find who you are.
Over to you Gwen Stefani.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
Entspresso keep me going
- What did I do consistently
to get to this point
and I think that would be,
to be really clear about
who I am and to go with that
and not try to be
something that you're not.
You'll stick out.
'Cause we're all very, very different,
but yet, all the same.
I think that, you know, it's
weird because in the early days
like everything was so homemade.
There was nobody telling us
what to do or how to do things.
Nobody telling me how to put my make up on
or how skinny to be, or
what costume to wear,
what song to write.
And I think that was a
really important thing
because it means that we
were really ourselves.
I think the inspiration just
came from like the creation,
you know, like to be able to
create and express yourself.
I truly think people need
to like just go inward
and go what do I like.
Who am I?
You know there's been people
that I've been fans of
like Julie Andrews or Emmy Lou Harris.
There was a band called Fishbone
that we used to go to all
their shows and of course,
but I honestly say that
really it's all about
like finding who you are.
- I think a lot of people
don't invest enough time
in finding out who they are.
It is so hard to set your goals
when you don't know what
it is that you want.
It's also really
challenging to live a life
that is fulfilling when you don't know
what truly makes you happy.
You see the reason why I know this,
because I went through it myself.
I spent a large chunk of my
life being very miserable
and I never invested the
time to find out why.
And on top of all that
I was so embarrassed
'cause I had a good life.
I was ashamed to tell
anybody that I was sad.
Instead I put on a fake front
and I continued on with my day.
Until one day, something
devastating happened to me.
My grandmother passed away.
And I remember finding out
in the back of an uber.
And I felt a pain so strong
that I would never forget that night.
And half of that pain was
the fact that I loved her
and I cared about her and
I wanted to see her again
but I knew I wouldn't be able to.
But the other half was the
absolute poison of regret
and not living my life
in the happiest possible way that I can.
So the next day,
I decided to do something
really, really drastic.
I started asking myself
really difficult questions.
I asked myself what is it that
was making me so miserable.
And it was my job.
The job that I had been
working at for 10 years
was making me absolutely miserable.
Then I asked myself a question.
Why did you choose this job?
I had to honestly answer it by saying,
I chose this job because I thought
it would make me a lot of money.
Why is it so important
to make a lot of money?
Well then I could buy things
and having things means I
have a higher social status.
Well why is it so important
to have a high social status?
Then I would be accepted
and loved.
Bingo.
So really, I wasn't after the money.
I wasn't after the job.
I wanted to be loved and accepted.
That's all I cared about.
And it was such a liberating experience
because I had that in my life.
I had that in my husband.
My husband loved me,
accepted me for who I was
in everything that I was.
I had friends who accepted me
and loved me unconditionally.
So I didn't need this job you see
and I didn't need the money.
So I decided to quit my job shortly after.
And I took on another job
that was a lot less stress.
And it opened up a lot of
time for me to do the things
I cared about and loved.
And one of the things
that I absolutely love
is being a dance teacher.
I loved going into my classes
and teaching people dance
and seeing everyone having a great time.
But I had to even dig a
little bit deeper than that.
What is it about dance
classes that made me so happy?
What made me really happy was
seeing the transformation in people.
Seeing them walk in not very
confident in their dance move,
and eventually being these
beautiful butterflies dancing
and seeing them discover who they are
and knowing that they could do anything
if they just work hard enough.
That's what made me really happy
about being a dance teacher.
So knowing all of that,
I decided to teach as many
dance classes as possible.
And I did.
And it brought me so
much joy and happiness.
And at the end of the semester,
when my students come up to me and hug me
I mean like really hug me to a point that
they're cutting off my circulation.
It is all the accolades that
I would ever need in my life.
Now you see, getting to
that point in my life
required me to really ask
myself tough questions
and also really answer them honestly.
And that is what I would
want to challenge you to do.
You know, ask yourself the questions.
Am I really living my life
according to my values?
What are my values?
What makes me truly happy?
Why am I doing this?
And maybe you have all the answers to it
and you already are living a great life.
And if you are, that's wonderful
and I want you to continue with that.
But if you're not,
don't be afraid to ask
yourself those questions
because the pay out of that is
absolutely wonderful and beautiful.
So the questions of the day is,
what are the changes that you have made
or are going to make to
find out who you are?
I also have a special shout out for Heidi.
Heidi thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
Evan's book, Your One Word.
His support means a lot to us
and I really hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
We believe in you and hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is,
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- You look back and you see
old Ariana to new Ariana
and you think about
how much you've learned
and how much you've grown.
It's insane.
- [Ariana] Yeah.
- Can you pinpoint one or two things
like the biggest thing you've learned
over the last maybe four years.
- When I guess when you just like...
be yourself, you know.
And in your most genuine possible way
and are completely unafraid.
That's when everything
starts to fall into place.
And that takes a while,
especially with so much
public, like you know,
rumors and opinions.
- Of course.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You get scared and you
want to hold back a little.
But then I was like, you know what,
none of this would be
happening if I would just show,
I was myself, and I went
out, and I was my silly self
and there you go and it all goes away.
And you're like, "that's me."
- It's a life changer.
- There you go.
Yeah, when you let go and
you're like here you go.
Take it or leave it.
That's as simple as it can be.
It's like why hold back, you want life.
Just have fun and be yourself
and don't worry about the rest.
It all falls into place.
- Honestly, I think everyone is
different and unique
and that's a good thing.
It's not bad, it's kind of
the best thing in the world.
You don't want to be like everyone else.
Growing up in high school,
and just junior high,
your whole life really, you
have been taught to feel like
or you want to be like everyone else
because conceptually you'll be included
and you'll be like the crowd
but when you think about it,
when you look at people like Lady Gaga,
who is so crazy and so
different, so unique.
And her whole message
is about being yourself
and being okay with it.
And she, the reason she
is so successful and so,
is because she's talented,
because she's different.
If she was just like Brittany Spears
or if she was just like me, Nina Dobrev,
then there would be two of us
so there'd be nothing special about that.
So I think what's special is
the fact that you're different
and is the fact that you're unique.
And that you can bring
something to the table,
so if anything, embrace that uniqueness
and that...
that thing that you have
that no one else does.
And expand upon it and make it better.
And tell everyone about it
and be confident about it,
because if you're confident
and happy and smiling,
you will attract confidence,
happiness, and laughter.
- I'm desperate for
people to start defining
their hopes and dreams and
wants and needs on their terms.
Not on what I say.
I don't care if you want
to hustle 18 hours a day.
I really don't, I really, really don't.
I don't care if you want
to buy the New York Jets.
I don't care what you want or need.
You need to care about
what you want and need.
You can't worry about what I'm saying.
You can't worry about whoever
your flavor of the month is.
Right, maybe I'm your flavor
of the month right now.
Maybe your consistent flavor of the life,
is your mom's point of view,
is your older brother, who's
guided you with good wisdom
but wants you to be a lawyer,
but you don't want to be a lawyer.
You want to be a street artist,
you want to take the chance
of being an entrepreneur
or the reverse.
Nobody preaches and loves
entrepreneurship more than me
but I think you see me all the time
talking about self awareness, are you one.
This is the golden era
for entrepreneurship.
People ask me for selfies.
This will go away.
It may not go away for me
but it's going to go away.
You know, entrepreneurship,
like a rap artist, like a baseball player,
like the heavy weight, nobody
cares who the heavy weight
champion of the world is right now.
Nobody cares who's an active astronaut.
But they surely did in 1969,
you know 1954 for the heavy weight champ,
or they change, they change
and it will always change.
And it will continuously change
and right now entrepreneurship
is in this pedestal,
it's having it's moment.
And what I'm fearful of, is
that you watch my videos,
you see my instagram quotes,
and what I want to
clarify for everybody is
I hope you understand, I am
not giving advice to everybody.
The only advice I'd like to
give to everybody is to do you.
Define what your north star is.
To understand yourself.
To understand what your work
life balance ambitions are.
What your financial ambitions are.
What your life challenges are.
The problems that you want
to try to solve and cure.
As we all do as humans
trying to climb those
different mountains in our lives.
What makes you tick?
That is all that matters.
I don't do all these daily
videos for you to be like me.
I don't think anybody should be like me.
Boy, there are enormous
amounts of pressures
and sacrifices that I recognize
that are not just healthy
or valuable to anybody else.
But its also not healthy or valuable to me
to do some of the things
that you want me to do.
Like its not fun for me
to work nine to five.
I will break.
I will be as equally
devastated as you would be
to work 'til midnight every day.
And so we just need a call
to action for everybody
to recognize we have to
stop judging everybody else.
I'm not judging you.
I'm creating content for
you to use as a barometer
to try to figure out what you
like and what you don't like
and I'm trying to provide
value through my words,
my actions, and my content
to bring to people to
amplify their worlds.
And that's really it.
That's the clarification.
Like I don't want people to be like me.
I don't want people to do me.
I want people to be themselves.
And they just have to start
with understanding themselves.
And not trying to be
like me in this moment
or that person in the next moment,
that person in the next moment.
The people that most win
are in tune with themselves
and figuring themselves out.